tu es une après le fromage un bon petit
coup de 20 depuis dimanche à bordeaux 43
pays sont représentés pour la 11e
édition de vinexpo c'est le premier
salon mondial pour les vins et
spiritueux 55 mille professionnels sont
présents pour parler 20 mais il ne
faudrait pas oublier qu'il y a en france
une exposition permanente ce sont les
routes des vins dans le bordelais ça
existe en alsace et en bourgogne aussi
les touristes sont de plus en plus
nombreux pour visiter déguster et
s'informer christophe medard et philippe
chasselas sont allés pour nous en côte
d'or
du côté de beaune des 16 côtes de beaune
la côte de beaune au minibus depuis 12
ans philippe scène arpente les vignobles
bourguignons pour les faire découvrir
aux touristes date bonne les troncs des
six le clos des hameaux le clos des
mouches la montère le tour dure deux
heures coûte 200 francs à ce prix là
fini les cars touristiques
la visite se fait à huit le contexte est
personnalisé beaune 1er cru clos des
mouches les places d honneur monsieur
noah ligoté nathalie gâteau les
touristes attendent de nous qu'on les
aide à comprendre la région parce que
deux vu de l'extérieur c'est quand même
pas si simple que ça les classifications
la notion de vignerons la notion de
vignobles les touristes apprécient cette
nouvelle façon de découvrir la bourgogne
pour moi c'est important d'être proche
des vignes de savoir précisément quel
vin et récolté comment il est fabriqué
près de deux millions de touristes
viennent chaque année en côte d'or et
pour l'hébergement ils choisissent de
plus en plus des chambres d'hôtes
comme ici au château de melun à 10km de
bonnes
pour 500 francs on est logé dans une
bâtisse du 16e siècle
les touristes adorent comme ça
romantique et avec les verts oui c'est
parfait je crois si vous voulez ensuite
une petite dégustation la dégustation
les touristes viennent d'abord pour ça
en bourgogne l'occasion d'apprécier les
vins de la région
90 on goûte peu quand on goûte beaucoup
on est obligé de recracher sinon au bout
de la cinquième ou la sixième au congrès
une goûte on est soudé ressemblerait à
fait jean charles côté intime le côté un
petit peu charmant traditionnelle et
puis surtout le contact
pour ceux qui aiment prendre de la
hauteur il y à la montgolfière en
bourgogne
r escargots vous invite à faire un
voyage impressionnant
spectacle magique que ces villages et
ses vignobles survolé à basse altitude
splendide